Yeah, that’s it.
It's perfect.
I knew it.
That's the Cadillac
of wet suits.
-Thanks, mom.
Aw, you grew, like, an inch.
My baby’s a big boy.
No, because typically
the white ones
get pulled over more.
I don't know why.
Chunky!
I invited you to
Thanksgiving.
Don't make me regret it.
C’mon don’t talk business.
It’s driving me crazy.
Not a long drive.
Those are my
grandma's napkin rings.
Come on, help me.
It’s almost ready!
Mommy?
Oh, if it's still dry
after all of this,
I'm going to kill
this thing again.
It won't be dry.
Wow.
You look gorgeous.
You're flirting with me.
You’re irresistible.
May I?
I’m just saying
it’s a lot of work
for a mediocre
piece of meat,
that's all I got to say.
Here, Denny.
Baste.
Be right back, I’m
gonna go check on
Ceil in the pool.
[DOOR BELL]
What am I gonna do with this?
Just baste it.
You know, pour the sauce on it.
Do I have to do everything?
Hey!
Okay.
Go help yourself to
drinks at the bar.
By the way, the table
looks beautiful.
These are amazing!
This is new.
Oh, Peg.
Oh, I love these.
Stop it,
you got this shot?
I need a copy.
Like right away.
No, no, no!
Yeah!
Anybody leave in
a stretcher yet?
Well, thank you.
Did you see grandma’s
napkin rings on the table?
You look amazing.
You see Stewie?
[SPLASHING]
Do not drown each other.
Anybody who ends up dead,
you're going to have
a problem with me.
Here.
Bob for apples!
That’s safe, okay?
Hey Ethan, no, no.
Wait for Denny to come
out to help you.
Denny!
Peggy, this is some house.
Tell me about it.
It ought to be.
I told you it was a showplace.
Where is he? Denny!
Denny!
DEA with a search warrant!
DEA with a search warrant
demand entry!
Blue pig!
Blue pig, blue pig!
Blue pig? Peg.
Master toilet.
Chunky, pool filter.
Let's go!
David, David, Amy! Let’s go!
Out of the pool!
Out of the pool, now.
Let's go, guys.
[CHAOTIC
COMMOTION]
Breach!
[BANGING]
DEA, we have a warrant.
We’re coming in.
[BANGING]
I asked you to spring for a stash house,
I begged you.
[FOOD PROCESSOR WHIRS, BANGING CONTINUES]
My kid is visiting.
You ruined the
holiday, Denny.
It’s not me, it's
the plumbing.
[GLASS SHATTERING]
[DOGS BARKING]
Happy f*cking
Thanksgiving, by the way.
Never again.